foreign
comes from Randy in Virginia I'm having
my first baby next month and my parents
want to move to my town to see the baby
more often they want to buy a house but
would have to sell theirs at first to
make it happen and are too lazy to go
and apply for a loan oh man I thought I
would just buy them a house and then
they could be my renters I currently
have fifty thousand dollars left on a
200 don't left 250 000 mortgage of my
current home they are in their 70s so if
they bought the home they would pass
they would pay less taxes and claim
homestead would it be smarter for them
to buy the home themselves or is it okay
for me to buy it and make them my
renters this is just the this is just
easiest so they can sell their house and
slowly move into the new one new house
New City stress-free because my dad has
a ton of stuff
man Randy
okay first and foremost love the uh
love the heart and the idea that you
want to help your parents uh but no
Randy no you buying a home
uh for them to be your renters not a
good plan and then on top of that you
don't have the money for it I mean you'd
be taking out a second mortgage so
absolutely not
um I think that you can invest in some
plane tickets for them if they want to
come see the baby a few times a year or
they can come just stay at your house
but if they want to move
home their home
full time and live in a new city that
needs to be on their time
yeah they need they're like grown-ups
and stuff
and so they need to do their own deal
besides that dude you never rent to
someone in the second paragraph when in
the first paragraph you called them lazy
so true it's just a basic concept here
as a landlord let me help you with that
okay so if your first description is
lazy and the next description is renter
this is on you so no no they they need
to handle this it's sweet that they want
to come be with a grandbaby I completely
get that if I don't know how great
grandkids are going to be I'd have been
nicer to their parents I completely get
this I understand I agree with the move
so Mom and Dad put their house up for
sale when it sells they can make the
move and buy a house in your city that's
how like normal people do it and stuff
and that's what they need to do so
um and if they get to your city with a
pocket full of money from the sale of
their house and can't find a home right
away they can rent from someone else
please
keep the grandparents
at an arm's length transaction don't let
the grandparents be your renters no it
was just so much that can go wrong with
that and the sad thing is it all will
happen it'll all go wrong